За два місяці до запуску рейсів Ryanair з України в Європу,  найбільший європейський
лоукост-перевізник відмовляється заходити на український ринок.
Причина – недосягнення згоди з аеропортом «Бориспіль». Гендиректор аеропорту
звинуватив авіакомпанію в шантажі та висуванні незаконних та завищених вимог.
Деталі переговорів трималися в таємниці, аж поки свою версію на прес-конференції не оголосив гендиректор аеропорту "Бориспіль" Павло Рябікін.
Більшість з вимог лоукостера, оголошених Рябікіним, порушують українське законодавство,
проте неможливо сказати: це остаточний список, чи тільки відправна точка у переговорах.
З досвіду перемовин Ryanair з іншими аеропортами у Європі можна стверджувати: авіакомпанія часто займає непоступливу позицію.
Так, минулого року Ryanair попрощався з аеропортом Осло - через новий "екологічний" податок.
У зв"язку з підвищенням податку на 2,5 відсотки авіакомпанія згорнула і дві свої італійські бази - Альгеро на Сардинії та Пескера на Адріатиці.
Два роки тому вона закрила свою єдину базу в Данії - у Копенгагені - у відповідь на вимогу місцевої влади покращити умови праці пілотам та членам екіпажу.
Замість цього лоукостер "переїхав" у Вільнюс. Перед тим Ryanair пішов з Марселя - він закрив усі 13 рейсів, щоб не йти на поступки французькому уряду,
який також вимагав кращого соціального захисту для пілотів. Ще раніше авіакомпанія закрила низку маршрутів з Единбурга,
зі скандалом заявивши, що аеропорт не дає їй додаткові знижки.
В ситуації з аеропортом "Бориспіль" на руках у Ryanair було багато козирів -
на хвилі «безвізу» громадскість вимагала термінової  появи в Україні популярних європейських лоукостерів,
міністерство інфраструктури оголосило про прихід Ryanair ще до підписання угоди.
A до контраргументів керівництва аеропорту "Бориспіль" було вкрай мало довіри -
через попередні скандали з конкурсом на посаду гендиректора, звинувачення в корупції та лобіюванні інтересів Міжнародних аваліній України.
Щоб збільшити тиск на "Бориспіль" авакомпанія навіть почала продавати білети ще до підписання угоди.
З досвіду поведінки авіакомпанії Ryanair в Європі можна зробити висновок, що і в Україні авіакомпанія вимагає максимально вигідних для себе умов.
Якщо ж на умови перевізинка не пристають, він зазвичай іде з ринку.
Адже поступки для одного аеропорту можуть потягти за собою претензії з боку інших.
Ще одним важелем впливу на аеропорт "Бориспіль" та український уряд є громадськість, розчарована відмовою Ryanair від України.
І схоже, цей козир подіяв: в  уряді вже заявили, що спробують поновити переговори з лоукостером.